in today's ad on your side it may be
time for you to get rid of all your
passwords wouldn't that be nice apple
google and microsoft are working to get
rid of them instead some new technology
will let you log into your accounts with
just one method
sound confusing or great john langler
explains
you probably have more passwords than
you can remember and it's a challenge to
keep all of them in your head and then
you have to use the same one it opens
you up to a cyber attack it's a problem
well now tech giants are working
together so you can ditch your passwords
forever fundamentally what we're doing
is letting you use your everyday device
the same thing that you do
multiple times a day to unlock your
device now to log in in a way that is
just leaps and bounds more secure than
anything that you're doing today megan
shamas is with the authentication
company leading the charge it's the fido
alliance fido is short for fast identity
online some people say oh it sounds like
a dog but that's actually on purpose
because
fido actually the latin
means to trust which we do our our dogs
and our puppies right but we also need
to trust our online logging in systems
microsoft estimates there are 921
password attacks per second the average
data breach costs a company more than 4
million dollars and they're becoming
more common attacks spiked 68 percent in
2021 from the year before this new
development would protect you instead of
storing your personal information on a
distant server where it can be stolen
and reused fido keeps your private data
cryptographically secure on your device
whatever you use to unlock your device
whether it be a face or a fingerprint or
pattern or pin you can then use it to
log in across all of your devices and
that data stays private to you
and importantly takes the need for a
password totally out of the equation
there's a good chance you're already
using some form of this technology so if
you log into websites or apps on your
phone with your facial id recognition or
maybe a fingerprint that's fido a new
partnership among the tech giants just
going to make that more common very
interesting john langley live local now